hallo mein name ist luca und ihr fragt
euch vielleicht wo bist du gerade heute
morgen noch aufgebracht in köln und mein
manager ilja und elias hinter der kamera
wie sie heute morgen doch in köln
aufgewacht weil ich eigentlich dachte
wir hätten den köln termine allerdings
hat er mich dann wird zum flughafen
gesteppte müssen nach berlin fliegen
dass die daten haben und dann sind
allerdings nach london geflogen und
jetzt sind wir irgendwie in london auf
jeden fall habe ich halt gedacht okay
bevor es heute wieder kein video kommen
gehe ich einfach zusammen mit ilja in
einem londoner supermarkt war im test
geboren haben uns ganz viele
verschiedene süßigkeiten gekauft und war
vor einigen jahren mit max in wales und
da haben wir auch schon eine solche
süßigkeiten probiert allerdings sind
jetzt einige neue dazugekommen ich würde
sagen wir fangen direkt mit den ersten
süßigkeiten also als erstes habe ich
hier die marge besser dass ein genie
babys tropical vorbereitet maine with
natural color sind flyer aus aber war
aber dass wir noch mal angepackt ich
werde jetzt mal so ein gelben hier
probieren also die fühlen sich sehr sehr
hart dann aber ich meine es ist eine
mischung aus gummibärchen und zucker
jetzt gerade gesagt im tutti frutti
heißen die in deutschland für die frau
die von haben womit diese papageien und
so und diese haben wirklich nur 74 gramm
zucker auf 100 gramm alt als der vega
wenig sie sind auf jeden fall echt geil
also das sind jetzt nicht so viele drin
aber die will ich auf jeden fall noch
ein paar von schnecken aber allerdings
machen wir direkt weiter mit den mini
genauso wie im alias rose ist auf die
wachteleier gegen diese alles hier so
ein bisschen oster mäßig unterwegs war
er bald ostern ist also die sehen
wirklich aus so wie richtige also ich
weiß nicht wie jetzt komplett zu essen
soll oder ob man die jetzt so in klassen
komplett neu ist diese steinhart alter
egal wie hart die sind diese
steinhardter also hier auf der
verpackung sind die auf jeden fall offen
aber ich stecke jetzt einfacher
anzuwenden und die schale noch krank war
weil sie irgendwo in london entwickelt
an england dann holt er fällt diese eier
ich warte moment ich habe es kalt ist
schon durch die durch wasser aufgegessen
und dargestellt als nächstes haben wir
hier
originell war übrigens wird morgen in
den block auf meinem kanal kommen wie
wir hier nach london geflogen sondern
sogar das ist ja was hartes das ist
genauso wahr dass sie nach kotze gesund
ernähren
gehört ist das egal als nächstes haben
wir direkt schon ich konnte meine
sprache jan weil werden sie nicht gerade
in london sind aber wir haben das nicht
zeigen das ist ja so ein kuchen ich habe
jetzt auf kellogg's oder sowas gibt
freute was natürlich erst mal dieses
ding hat auf jeden fall zucker des todes
schmeckt auch nur nach zucker und
marzipan es ist so ein bisschen wie so
eine mischung aus marzipan kugeln dies
ja meist nur zu weihnachten giften und
hin dass haben
kieselsteine oder irgendwie so nicht an
natürlich ist mal ist jetzt bezahlt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
mein gott stinkt das drei wochen später
[Musik]
wie hundefutter und schmecken nach unten
hier schon gemerkt hat damian ecke wo
alles liegt und hier war es gut es ist
das steht bisher das wasser machen vista
regel auf von der farbgestaltung ist
ähnlich wie milka also hab ich würde
sagen ich weiß jetzt a
da von außen haben von eben so sieht das
ganze aus
das kann man so ein bisschen mehr
menschen vergleichen denn eine harte
schale und weichem kern aber die harte
schale scheiße und beweist auch das
rheinland pfalz menschen regelt aber ich
habe irgendwie das wasser
ich merke gerade dass die meisten sachen
wirklich von diesem märz besser sind als
ihr werdet es da die zeile du bist zu
beginn setzten haben auch und von den
taten liege zu beginn wurden wir nicht
erforscht deswegen machen wir jetzt die
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wahl
das sind glaube ich genau die gleiche
einfach einen anderen formen die wir zu
beginn hatten meinte möchtegern
orangengeschmack also soll glaube ich
sauer sein aber es ist einfach so müsse
dieses pseudo sei
als nächstes haben wir hier ein
kellogg's und den habe ich mit bugs auch
schon gegessen und ich war natürlich
super sagte ackermann mit diesem ding
meinte bolt bolt guckt ihn euch an und
max und ich kann mich noch genau das
video erinnern max und ich habe den
gästen so war das in cornflakes in der
regel form mit krank viel zucker glas
schmeckt ja ja ja ich war ja die
konsistenz das teil wirklich ungesund
ist dieses essen wollte ich darf meine
damen und herren das ihr kommt dass ich
jetzt hier auf die linke seite zusammen
mit
das hier aus wie in mario anders im
brütend ich würde da überall erkannt von
der zuschauerin aus österreich hat so
eine engländerin form geben wir so ein
bild mache da war ihr blitz an so fast
50 47 59 schritt mache direkt weiter und
zwar mit der es war so sinnvoll dass wir
immer die größten packungen gekauft
haben diese carroll mitteilte sind alle
schon seit ausgepackt dass man muss das
wirklich nur so aufklappen oder wir
haben die benutzer warum gekauft so
sehen die teile aus also sehen nicht wie
diese milka riegel die wir gerade hatten
also ich beiße anadarko befreundet
wieder so ein harter kern dass man
meistens ein denkmal durch die red bull
habe mich ein bisschen groß ist aber
eines ist ein bisschen karl may be quick
nur auch nicht so wichtig ich habe noch
zwei sachen übrig freunde ein rad bus
und einer elika aus dort wasser
was soll ich nehmen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
red bull trostpreis ich bin überhaupt
keine schokolade trinken alles was wir
geholt haben so ein schokoladen regeln
genau da sich dort die ganzen polizei
[Musik]
was machst du heute so werden alle ich
nichts ich mache ich essen und damit los
ich habe mir schon wieder schusskraft
ist eine schwere über eine ewigkeit
später hallo war
schmeckt gut sagt das doch mega gut es
ist warm aber kalt es hat aber auch
müsse es ist groß
das ist die perfekte mischung aus allem
das recht muss es irgendwie alles nur
crazy also packe ich habe ja alles made
werde nur 80 gramm zucker pro 100 gramm
lakritze
ich dachte irgendwie liegt ja geil ich
hab's auftakt riss mir vertrauen was wir
hier drin hahahaha lakritze klingt das
schon alter ich hasse da kratze ich weiß
nicht wie menschen das feiern können die
jagd mit vor die kamera wir wissen jetzt
wer jemals an einen scherz ich hasse
auch mag jeder partie geboten also die
beiden haben jetzt hier diese vier
lakritz teile und ich würde sagen in der
duden ist jetzt hier sein gelbes ich
nehme jetzt hier sonst keiner an
es gibt nur die auf london baumeister
jetzt so london ihr lover da war ich
hab's ja christi wodurch das la kunden
und zwar das was ihr vom video meine
damen und herren wenn es euch gefallen
hat dann lasst doch gerne mal einen
leicht da hier haben wir jetzt alle
süßigkeiten die wir nicht so gut fanden
und hier vorne die wir gut folgen also
drei sachen karamell der bus riegel und
erzeugt so viel karamell bewusst riegel
kellogg's das ist denn mit diesem einst
die hotel seife ja dies gut
life is great meint